and minimalists hello everybody welcome
the minimalist podcast we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less
my name is Joshua Fields Milburn and I
am Ryan Nicodemus and together we are
the minimalists we got a special guest
today I am excited for this podcast man
we do it welcome to episode 149 today
we're gonna talk about sex and couples
and traditional relationships and
non-traditional relationships and a
whole lot more and because we're talking
about sex Ryan and I have never had sex
well not with each other
what wait I mean I've had sex before
dude you didn't know oh I totally lost
my virginity we're here with we're here
with dr. Christopher Ryan he's the
author of sex at Dunn and also you got a
book coming out hopefully next year or
the year after
I've even you've been painting it for
many years
civilized to death is the next book
which I'm sure we could talk about that
as well but welcome to the show thanks
man well before we dive in so the format
of this of the show is we we don't bring
guests on to interview anyone instead we
help people answer their questions so
we've we've got some some questions I
figured we would we would dive into
before we do that though Chris can you
tell me I mean I read sex Adan awhile
ago
and and it seemed relatively
uncontroversial to me but there seems to
be a whole lot of controversy behind
some of the ideas that you've put forth
in that book why exactly do people feel
so is it is it that people feel that
their belief structures are being
challenged or or why yeah I I can't
really comment on motivation right but I
think there are different sources of
disagreement I think and it's
interesting because very little of the
disagreement is factual it's sort of an
overall all that books [ __ ] there's
a lot of cherry-picking it's you know
it's been debunked I read that all the
time it's been debunked who the hell do
but it and and how did it get bunked in
the first place but I I think largely
people disagree with the
general notion that women are sexual
beings I think that's a big part of it
nobody seems to have a problem with the
argument that men are highly sexual
beings that are attracted to variety and
novelty and sexual partners I think
that's so obvious that it's kind of hard
to even conceive of a disagreement with
that but where we applied that to women
as well and actually said women may be
even more sexual beings than men men in
some ways you know with the multiple
orgasms and the fact that you know a
woman could conceivably have sex with
five men in one session whereas a guy
you know guy has sex he has an orgasm
and it's like what's on TV you know it's
kind of finished mm-hmm so I think
that's what people find offensive
not everyone by the way a lot of people
thank God find it liberating and and
stimulating I've received dozens of
emails from women saying that they had
to stop and masturbate every 10 pages
when they were reading
I've never gotten a single email from a
dude assume that's happening I I mean I
think what it's interesting because I
think that for women the lifting of the
shame and the feeling of liberation like
oh I'm not sick there's nothing wrong
with me all my life I've been told that
I'm not supposed to feel sexual desire
the way men do and it's natural for men
but it's shameful for me so to read
something that says no no it's natural
for you we're Homo sapiens men and women
we're actually very similar right women
find that often very liberating and and
erotic and and interesting so so in a
way like you're giving them permission
to to be a sexual person to be a second
yeah given them permission to be a human
being Homo sapiens that's that's the
argument of the book and not not just
women but just all human beings in
general that there's sort of this
puritanical veil that has been placed
over our culture where even talking
about the the topic of sex for some
reason like I feel vulnerable just just
in our culture it's a thing that's
almost
boo just even you're bringing up that
word and you get something to talk about
in public yeah it's not to say that we
shouldn't have private lives there are
certainly things that I won't talk about
in public but sex I certainly shouldn't
be ashamed or embarrassed to to talk
about sex and in a public forum
especially in a way that serves the
greater good yeah especially with
something that isn't just like a part of
life but it's I mean it's necessary for
a life and it's it's funny how this
there's this act that we have to have to
keep the human race going but yet we're
so well a lot of us are very embarrassed
or it is taboo to kind of talk about in
public well don't you also think that
that that's one of the reasons though is
we've treated as as only an act that is
to keep the human race going and and I
think what you're exposing is the other
side of this well we can also have sex
for pleasure you know it doesn't just
have to be functional right right man
Mariah nice bedroom game is about to
change well with that said let's go
ahead and dive into some questions
before we dive in can I talk about
something that was in the news I just
want to get your all's take on this okay
I'm saying it is but I saw this story
about this woman who was getting is
about sex but it's kind of I guess along
the lines but this woman who is getting
married and she basically put out and
asked to all of her guests saying hey I
want a hat I want to be a Kardashian for
a day and I want everyone to gift me
$1500 for for the wedding of my dreams
well this like and did you hear about
this so it ended up not happening like
basically some people did supporter that
you know could afford the fifteen
hundred bucks but essentially she didn't
have enough guests RSVP and sent her
money so it was like this just this
social media tyrant on how all of her
friends and family their pieces of
garbage and how no one really cares
about her and how you know it's not a
lot to ask for fifteen hundred bucks I
would have thought that you guys would
heard about this and it was it's been
all over the news
really it's crazy yeah but but I mean I
don't understand what I don't understand
so my media blocks anything that has the
word Kardashian you mine usually does -
well I mean I mean I guess that's what
really that's why I wanted to talk
about it is because you know we have
this society where had involves a lot of
reality TV and you know you could look
at this with sex to like how there are
these lifes that are presented to us
that it makes us feel like oh if we're
not doing life this way then we're not
doing it right and the same thing can be
said with sex too I think like you know
porn is one of those things where like I
don't have anything against porn but
there is you know some porn where it's
like that is it is what most porn is
staged it is not you know not normally
how a couple is going to make love
sometimes yes but that's not like the
that's not the way that one should be
doing it and I guess I'm just speaking
to the just the dangers of maybe reality
TV or even like comparing ourselves to
others I just wanted to to get you
guys's take I mean that's absolutely
insane right I mean it almost sounds
fake right it sounds to be like you're
trying to distinguish fantasy from from
reality you know I've got a
five-year-old daughter and I we pretend
there's a Santa Claus we also tell her
there isn't this actual being like the
supernatural being called Santa Claus we
the same way that when she watches you
know Daniel tiger on Mister Rogers
neighborhood like she doesn't think that
puppet is a real sentient creature she
is able to understand that it's
make-believe and in a way maybe one of
the problems is we don't understand that
the Kardashians are make-believe or a
lot of pornography is make-believe as
well and and you know there's nothing
inherently wrong with watching porn we
can obviously get addicted to it just
like we can get addicted to anything
else and and that's when it becomes a
problem not not the the device or the
the whatever we're consuming itself yeah
so the fantasy marriage whether it's you
know Kardashian or just a huge expense
of money and the white gowns and that
all that stuff is part of the fantasy
world that and then we could say the
expectations of the relationship often
are part of a fantasy world as well that
we're not distinguishing from reality
yeah which you know to get back to the
book that that's one of the things we're
talking about this fantasy that you
because you love someone you're going
be sexually attracted to them forever
and not to anyone else that's Santa
Claus
that's absurd yeah yeah that's not
reality but people are comparing their
actual experience to that fantasy and
they're feeling like there's something
wrong with them or wrong with their
partner or wrong with their marriage
because it doesn't live up to that
ridiculous fantasy right well the word
you use there is expectation right and
if it's my expectation that my partner
Rebecca is is never going to be
attracted to another man as long as I'm
with her then I've just set myself up
for failure or I'm I'm I'm being so
ignorant like it's like I've got these
blinders on and man as soon as someone
removes one of those blinders I'm going
to be devastated mainly because there's
a poor expectation there we were in
Portland this week and I was at the
Portland Art Museum and there was like
this neon art sign on the wall I said
expect a miracle and and I think I think
that's okay too I mean not in the not in
the religious sense but but like maybe
all of this is a miracle but maybe we're
expecting the wrong miracle and one of
those miracles is I'm going to meet the
you know Prince Charming or the princess
that I'm going to live with happily ever
after that's the wrong expectation
maybe the expectation is I'm going to be
good to someone in hopes that they're
also going to I'm going to get something
out of that relationship yeah I I guess
what I'm taking from this is we have to
really be careful with the fantasies
that we indulge in and we have to be
able to separate those fantasies from
actual life and expectations because
just like we've been saying when your
expectations are so high and you don't
have this amazing perfect situation
unfolding like you have laid it out I
mean this girl who I'm talking about it
route she's not with her fiance anymore
she's not friends with her friends and
she's not friends with their friends and
family anymore I mean it's like this
huge thing and it's and it's not I'm not
trying to get down on this girl as much
as like I want to help her and I want to
help people out there who are just
indulging in these fantasies and
expecting their life's to be that way if
that's the expectation we set for
ourselves
yeah it's we can be in for a world or
hurt so yeah again I guess we just have
to be careful with
I guess the fantasies we indulge in and
how how much we try to I don't know live
up to those fantasies I guess I don't
problem of the fantasies right the
problem of the the problem seems to be
pretending they're they're actually real
yeah
and assuming they're real and I think
that's where we're this we're this idea
of well that's where the discontent
really comes from is thinking that well
this is how it is going to be even
though that is it's not reality yeah no
I think we should dive into these
questions our first voicemail is from
jerome in pennsylvania would you say
this intentionality or vanity influenced
users to look for specific
characteristics in a partner such as
height hair color or other physical
traits to provide an attraction as a
person who enjoys the anchorage sex and
needs me the intimacy that sex provides
is important to me that my partner's
beliefs about an intimacy align with my
home beliefs our relationship lacking
intimacy simply won't be fulfilling for
me but to me there is a physical
component to attraction and it will be
difficult for me to be intimate with a
partner I'm not attracted to physically
on some level and yet we're often told
that looks no matter it's what's inside
that counts
this makes me feel guilty for initially
choosing partners based on who I have in
a sexual attraction to all this is
possible if I follow this age-old vise I
may end up feeling unfulfilled I'm will
enough to know that a person's physical
characteristics not everything in a
relationship but can it be a factor in
the equation and get things started or
must be I'll be social pariahs for
having a preference so of course I think
it has to be part of the equation I mean
unless you're asexual which is
definitely a thing but but if you want
to be an intimate relationship with
someone having a an attraction now what
our attraction strategy is is different
for each of us he talked a little bit
about about Jerome's question here yeah
I think I think a mistake that people
often make is conflating attraction with
[Music]
compatibility in a long-term
relationship right I think it's
important to disentangle those and sort
of think about them
as separate issues because physical
attraction as Jerome said can sort of
get it started can draw you to someone
chemistry yeah but often chemistry is
the result of psychological
incompatibility right I think a lot of
times what we do in relationships is we
choose a partner who will sort of draw
us toward issues that we have trouble
with and so that can be a source of
growth because you're drawn to these
issues that you're troubled by and you
can work through them in a B yeah
or you just keep banging your head
against them and you have one of these
like dramatic but crazy relationships
that a lot of people get into which can
be sexually really fulfilling right the
makeup sex can be amazing all the
yelling and screaming and breaking
things can get really hot if you're you
know that kind of person but I think
that it's important to sort of
disentangle those things because the
attraction will fade over time as you
become family you know use you live with
someone for 10 years they become a
sibling right I don't care how hot they
are yeah as the level of familiarity
increases the the level of physical
chemistry often decreases right and and
again that's one of those things that
people often blame themselves for or
think that's you know they're told that
there's something wrong with their
relationship because every month Cosmo
has ten more tricks for keeping it hot
in bed forever you know it's a bunch of
[ __ ] yeah so there's a book called
the erotic mind by again a guy named
Jack Morin and I read a long time ago
but the thing I remember is is he says
this very simple formula he says
attraction plus an obstacle equals
passion and so you think about every
relationship every love story Romeo and
Juliet or whatever there's that initial
attraction and then there's a
problem there's a reason they can't get
there right the families won't let him
or it's a long-distance thing or she's
already married or it's two dudes and
they're gay and they can't tell anyone
or whatever it is there's always some
obstacle and so the the attraction keeps
building and building to try to overcome
that obstacle but once we remove the
obstacle you get together there's no
obstacle anymore the passion diminishes
and so it's weird it's like what are we
trying to do you meet somebody you're
really into you want to be with them all
the time right so you're sabotaging your
own passion it's interesting but yeah
anyway to get to his point I I think
it's really important to separate those
things so there's nothing wrong with
saying look I'm only I'm really
attracted to like you know short blondes
with you know big knees or something but
don't mistake that for compatibility
right so you might find the perfect
short blonde with big knees and that
doesn't mean that you guys are good
together
right it just means you like looking at
pictures of her right yeah I think that
that if I were to sum up what you're
saying there is is looks do matter in
terms of attraction but in terms of
long-term compatibility maybe something
like values matter you know if you have
radically opposing values and beliefs
even though you might be really
attracted to each other sexually right
yeah you might have a great sexual
encounter but but in terms of looking
for a long-term relationship but I think
is gonna fall apart and even worse
you're probably gonna stick it out
longer because of that well the passion
that you've just described the amount of
kids and by the time you figure out that
you're not a good match for each other
there are other innocent people involved
now yeah that's the real tragedy I think
it's fine have a good time you're
attracted to a certain type of person
physically have a good time but don't
mistake that for partnership for
compatibility and don't start try to
start a family with somebody because you
like the way she looks or he looks yeah
also you might have a type right lately
you might have a type that you're
attracted to but that doesn't mean
that's the only type of person you're
attracted to is a lobby I think of X my
partner whom you met when we were out
your house and Topanga and
she is not my type at all but let in
terms of light what I would
traditionally date you know I used to
date shorter women and exes you know
tall she's almost my height and she has
darker hair than what I would date
normally it's like they're all these
things we were like well if I were to
just pick what is my type
it would unlikely be her however I'm
still wildly attracted to her not in
spite of her physical look she looks
gorgeous but realizing like there can be
a whole spectrum of attractiveness as
well I don't have to just have the short
blonde with the big knees and so I what
what I realized though with her is is
the thing that keeps me attracted is the
fact that we do share so many
similarities outside of we asked were
attractive physically but with
everything else beyond that sort of aids
the physical attraction yeah and I think
that's part of maturity too I don't know
how old this dude is but I mean a lot of
guys you know 20 22 23 24 like they're
very focused on the visual you know and
that's fine the you know experience
those things but don't don't you know
get yourself into a situation that is
gonna have long-term implications for
for other people then when you're in
your 30s maybe you will have matured
enough to be like hey okay I've been
there I've done that and now I'm looking
a little under the surface with the big
knees yeah yeah I've been down there
right I think it's I think it's crazy to
say that looks don't matter like I you
know you hear that I'm kind of
propagated it sounds virtuous it does on
the surface yeah
I am NOT shallow at all right would it
matter for some things and not for
others right and oh that's a great way
to put it yeah yeah well I mean there
there is something to be said about how
we've evolved up to this point too about
how these characteristics that we look
for it is almost a survival mechanism in
a lot of ways so you know I think for
that for that aspect like it's kind of
well it's it
arts are not stacked for us I mean
they're stacked against us when it comes
to looks don't matter like looks
absolutely matter it's I think it's
programmed into our into our DNA I love
what you said about the love plus an
obstacle equals passion attraction
attraction yeah attraction plus obstacle
legal mmm it's it's like almost kind of
reiterates or affirms that whole thing
of you know it's not about the
destination it's about the journey and
looking at that specifically with sex I
mean it totally makes sense so when you
get into a relationship where maybe you
are attracted to the person drop-dead
gorgeous ten years pass and you get to
this point where yes you're comfortable
maybe you're not as you know sexually
attracted because of that familiarity
thing that we were talking about maybe a
you know to get over that hump it is
it's about putting in some type of
obstacle or putting in some type of of
excitement I haven't got to that point
with Mariah but it's interesting because
if that's the equation for passion then
there are I feel like there are ways
that people who have been in
relationship for 20 years they can find
a way to maybe make an obstacle or make
something to yeah to create more passion
in the relationship vacation separately
yeah you know interesting notice each
other that is an interesting concept
it's like intermittent fasting right
yeah I mean really it's the same sort of
thing it's like you want to appreciate
your food more be hungry
yeah right yeah but if you're just
sitting in the kitchen all day eat and
every time you have a slight pang of
hunger well you're never gonna be hungry
and then you're not gonna really pay
attention to your food either that
fourth piece of chocolate cake is not
nearly as satisfying as as the meal that
you've had even a really healthy meal
you've had after an 18 or 20 hour fast
Bex and I we spend a week on week off
just based on some some geographical
issues that we have so so our daughter
or her biological father lives in
Montana still and so she has to
basically shuttle back and forth and so
we spend we spend a week apart every
other week
and I could tell you that obstacle
certainly leads to a whole lot more
chemistry when we are together
cuz of that that time apart it's we're
vacationing apart every other week
basically and man it's difficult it
really is difficult and there are times
where I'm just like I want to say [ __ ]
this like this is this is way too hard
to deal with I wish you were here right
now but of course if you were here 24
hours a day then something I would take
it for granted but it would be granted
yeah yeah so when it comes to looks and
relationships I think that we we should
be clear what our preferences are and we
should like honor those preferences but
putting those as number one that is not
going to create a great relationship so
like when I started looking for a
partner when I started doing online
dating
that's how I met Mariah like I had this
thing where I was like yes I want to be
attracted to someone I do want there to
be some sexual attraction but I'm not
going to not go on a date with a girl
just based upon her looks because it is
very possible to meet someone that you
know maybe isn't your ten out of ten
with looks but personality is 10 out of
10 and that does make sometimes it does
make a difference
sure so so are you in you Duncan talking
about this on your podcast so Chris has
a podcast called tangentially speaking
and I think he said something about he
met a 70 year old woman who was one of
the sexiest what women he's ever met and
and part of that it had very little to
do with her looks it had to do with her
sort of there was a particular
confidence and almost like this aura
around her
he said she was really good in bed
[Laughter]
alright well I wasn't one line that came
to me someone said he was Oscar Wilde
maybe you said men learn to love women
they're attracted to and women learn to
be attracted to men they love so there
is also a gender difference in this
question I think it's probably true that
women are less tied to the visual than
men are certainly young men
and we're creating a monolith here it's
not viously different Airport planning
exceptions yeah it's a spectrum for
everyone that is like what why why is it
different for men and women that way I
know you do write a little bit about in
in sexathon about how it used to be
where a woman had to rely on a man for
for shelter for food I mean there were
well that's the that's the narrative we
argue against actually I'm sorry and our
narrative that women relied on men for
shelter and food and all that in
prehistoric times there's turns out
there's very little evidence for that
certainly after agriculture that became
the norm and so you know the idea that
women are attracted to men for their
wealth we argue is an artifact of post
agricultural context that that's not
biological because in the prehistoric
pre-agricultural times where resources
were shared egalitarian hunter-gatherer
societies women didn't need to rely on
men to bring them meat or shelter or
protection or these things so that's
sort of one of the the schisms between
what we arguing sex are done in the
mainstream view and what actually yeah
so so I mean I guess going back to the
question is there I guess it's just like
a I don't know a Bible I mean comes on
to biology I don't know what why women
would care less about looks than than
men would is there is there any reason
behind that well I I mean there are lots
of different theories for that I think
one of them could be sperm competition
which is another thing we talked about
in sex at dawn where if a woman's having
sex with three or four different men
within the same menstrual cycle their
sperm will fight it out within her and
she has women have biological mechanisms
that choose the sperm that's most
compatible with her oh wow
and so often the the man who would be
the best match for her biologically
is not necessarily the best-looking guy
it's the visuals are not the main
component or the main indication of
biological compatibility at least in
terms of the compatibility of immune
system so we talked about the research
done by Klaus Wedekind in Switzerland he
was the first to do this research where
he was trying to understand why women's
sense of smell is so much more acute
than men's and his he was I think he
remember this anecdote I think this
applies to him where he was listening to
some of his students talking and the
women were saying something about like
yeah this guy's cute but he doesn't
smell right and so like that and he
thought man I've never heard a man say
that you know I've never heard a man say
man she's hot but this smells not quite
right you know so that's what spurred
him to think about this stuff and his
his hypothesis was that there it's about
immune compatibility immune system
compatibility so to simplify this
oversimplify it let's say there are five
components of it's called major
histocompatibility index I think there
are five components of immune response
that correspond to five different types
or classes of pathogens right and so he
said okay I'm gonna find a bunch of
women who are low they're fine on four
but they're low on one so they're low on
type one they're low on type two low and
type three and so on and then I'll find
men who have the same you note variation
so he's fine on four but he's low on
type 1 or Laura
so his thesis his hypothesis was that a
woman who's low on type one will not be
attracted to a man who's low on type one
because they're kids would have this
vulnerability she's gonna want to be
with someone who's high on type one to
compensate for her mmm you know
vulnerability there so what he did was
he had these guys wear t-shirts for
three days and nights no deodorant no
shower no soap yeah and then they put
the t-shirts in a ziplock bag and then
the women would smell the t-shirts and
marked how attractive they thought the
men were just based on those smell of
their
tshirt right and he found that about 80%
of the women chose correctly they chose
men who were high in what they were low
in right but about 20% of the women
seemed to be choosing randomly so here
II ran the study same same thing same
thing 20% what is it
birth control pills right those women
were on birth control so it short
circuits that system for for picking up
whether or not the guy's gonna be a good
match no none of this is happening
consciously right so he might be Brad
[ __ ] Pitt but he smells wrong right
yeah
whereas you know all three of us you
know looking at whatever Salma Hayek is
like fine I don't care what she smells
all right fine I'm in there so it's a
there's a biological difference between
the way men and women assess a potential
partner I think I think the answer for
Jerome is that just get some sweaty
shirts start mailing them out to women
and see what happens man no Jerome I'd
love to send you a copy of our book
minimalism live a meaningful life in
there since we talked about values it
getting clear on what your values are
it's pretty important I know when I was
going partner hopping for the longest
time part of that was I just wasn't
clear on what type of person I wanted to
be right and I think if you don't know
the type of person you want to be it's
hard to find the person that matches
with your your ideal self yeah or the
person you are yeah you know which is
hopefully who you want to be you're in
line you know your current actions are
in line with what your future self wants
to be if not then then getting clear on
what those values are will at least give
you a path on which you can you can
travel so Shawn if you could reach out
to him send him a copy of minimal have
meaningful life or the audio book or the
book book or the e-book it looks like
our next question is from Sarah I don't
know where she's from but she says she's
asking for a friend
I have about 20 pairs of very nice
lingerie and other sexual items I've
been single for seven years I have
already minimized my collection twice
and I feel like I have the basic store
down to one box what to do with it just
for when relationship items
you're not in a relationship I get zero
value from these items alone the next
relationship could always be right
around the corner I hope so Josh what do
you do with all your old lingerie I'm
wearing some of it right now
no I it's funny like so the reason that
that Sarah's asking this question is you
know we often talk about getting rid of
unused items if I'm not finding value in
something then maybe someone else can
but there are some things that are
harder to donate than other things like
sex toys or a lingerie there's one thing
that if you come come too if you come to
use the sex toy shop patent pending the
view court of our house and we have an
entire bin of sex toys Beck's and I do
played again sex toys and so like I
don't think that the fact that that
sarah has has 20 pairs of lingerie is in
and of itself a problem if that's the
only thing the average American house
has 300 thousand items in it if you have
20 pieces of lingerie and you got rid of
all 20 of them it doesn't really put a
dent in everything else what 20 pieces
of lingerie or a whole bunch of sex toys
that aren't that aren't curated
intentionally it's it's symptomatic of
of this like broader sort of deficit
that you're experiencing like I feel my
like my life is incomplete my sex life
is incomplete so I'm going to bring
something in that is going to make it
more complete that's how I look at sex
toys or lingerie or whatever else we do
in the bedroom these sex toys I have
augment the experience of sex as opposed
to as opposed to well it's not a very
good sex life well the best sex toys in
the world aren't going to make a
terrible sex life
outstanding overnight they instead they
enhance they amplify the the experience
of what's going on in the bedroom so I
mean the fact that sarah has 20
pairs of lingerie or lingerie laying
around she's saying they're just for win
items yeah we like to delineate just in
case or just for when just in case of
these things that you like you're giving
yourself permission hold on - even
though you're never actually going to
use them again if that's the case if
you're actually never going to use them
then please get rid of them there
they're getting in the way there
obviously and right now there's
psychological clutter for her if you
feel like you're never going to use them
you're unlikely to use them in the
future then by all means get rid of them
if you know you're gonna use them at
some point then hold on to them for
whatever period you feel comfortable for
yeah it's funny I think about I don't
know man like if I if Mariah had a bunch
of lingerie before I met her I mean I
would totally be acceptable accepting of
that and you know appreciate her dress
and sexy for me but and this is just my
own personal preference us going out and
buying a lingerie outfit for Mariah
that's much for me that's a much more
sexual much more fun sexual experience
yeah and it's and I'm like I know that
I'm the only man that has seen I mean
not that I'm like super jealous and
protective but I mean there is something
about you know breaking in that outfit
and you know is her and either broken in
not like this oh I wonder how many how
many other dudes she's worn this piece
of lingerie for again that would not
deter me from dating Mariah at all but
there is a different experience I think
that happens from having some used
lingerie that you've had your entire
life and then bringing in something new
that with a new partner I think I think
the psychological part there there's
some sort of psychological downside yeah
Iren maybe you can speak to this because
Chris you have a very healthy
perspective on on things like this but I
remember there was a girl I was dating
who wanted me to use this [ __ ] ring she
had I'm like all right no problem and
I'm like wait a minute wait a minute how
many guys have used this and I'm like
nom I'm good with using one I just don't
want to use even the
I'm sure she washed it took care of it
and all these other things like there
was a psychological barrier there can
you talk about some of those
psychological barriers maybe what's
wrong with me it was it the right size
extra medium I do know more about sex
toys than I do apparently I had no idea
you were such an expert that's great I
don't know that I'm much of an expert I
just know the becks and I have
experimented a lot and it's not in a way
so I want to keep our relationship fresh
but it's just like but maybe that that's
part of it just like tools I think what
I like in you know I probably owe you
$60 after this therapy session here but
I'm from Dayton Ohio $60 a week's pay in
Dayton yeah well I think it's part of it
is the newness like like doing
experiencing something new with someone
like you talked about with going to buy
lingerie with Mariah as opposed to as
opposed to the thing that she's used for
many years with multiple partners which
by the way it's not a deal breaker
either way but there is a preference
that I have for sure well you're you're
pointing out that it's not about the
thing it's about the experience yes
absolutely
yeah I think that's in and yeah if
something happened to all the sex toys
we have at home I'm not gonna feel any
particular way about other than
inconvenience by having to buy new ones
but even then it would be like oh like
bringing these things in intentionally
because it isn't about the thing I don't
actually get the value from the thing
it's what I do with the the thing you
know it's funny it's talking about the
thing the sex toys earlier you said that
sex toys aren't gonna make your sex life
better and I do agree with you in the
sense that if if I had a really shitty
sex life me going out and buying sex
toys is gonna all of a sudden make my
sex life awesome right but I do think
that the sex toys it can yes enhance the
all the experience that's happening
already but what I have found is that
sex toys help with helping people get
more comfortable with themselves helping
people to be okay with exploiting their
bodies in different ways we're we're you
know having specific sex toys will will
kind of force you into experimenting
with your body in different ways
depending on which sex toy you get where
otherwise without that tool it's it's
not I feel like it's not as easy to you
know experiment with yourself does that
make sense or not there's a lot of shame
this is safe space here I think I think
a lot of has to do with shame like and
even even you're saying the word butt
plug we say it jokingly because like
there's almost like this puritanical we
should never get pleasure from something
like that especially as a man it's
thinking anything in my but that's
that's gay and I can't be gay even if a
woman does it it's gay like it's it's
the it's a this cultural stigma or like
taboo like yeah yes sorry yeah I know
you're right and and and so so what do
we do to get around that I mean it has
to do with getting comfortable with that
discomfort yeah I think the toys help
augment that in a way that that maybe
you wouldn't otherwise and when I say
toys it could also be the the lingerie
that she's holding on to right yeah you
know it doesn't matter how strong or
fast I am I mean I'm not I'm not as fast
as a you know J 900 vibrator bounty
that's a real one of those all right
well Sarah I'd love to send you a copy
of sex at dawn Sean if you could reach
out to Sarah and send her a copy of that
I would appreciate it I don't know if
it'll tell you what to do with your
lingerie but it might tell you why
you've evolved to to want to wear
lingerie if you read between the lines
anyway we'd love to hear what y'all have
to say so if you have a comment or tip
about sex or sex toys apparently
including advice for any of our callers
today leave us a voicemail for 0 6 2 1 9
7 8 3 9 you can also email a voice memo
to podcast at the minimalists comm where
our favorite comments and tips on a
future episode and stay tuned to the end
of this episode for this week's listener
comments and tips Ryan what time is it
it's time for our lightning round where
we answer questions from social media
we're on Twitter Facebook and Instagram
at the minimalists now Chris this is
what we do on a lightning round we try
to give someone pithy shareable less
than 140 character response you don't
have to worry about that though what we
do is we just really Mandar on quite a
bit and eventually we tie it up with a
little bow that is sometimes tweetable
right usually not though but we also
keep all those tweetable sayings in one
place too minimal maxims calm ryan
what's our first question
our first lightning round question is
from hano hano writes is building an
emotional base necessary for a healthy
sexual life Chris yeah does she mean
with or he mean with the partner or
anyone itself I think what they're
saying is is to have that's a great
point actually but I think what they're
asking is in order to have a healthy sex
life where you can look at it as a good
sex life do you have to build this
emotional foundation first in order to
have good sex that's the way I take the
graduation show yeah I think it depends
what you mean by good sex but maybe you
mean fulfilling sex yeah
yeah that could also what see I took it
I misunderstood the question because I
took it to mean within oneself you know
like getting back to your
earlier like who you want to be and I
said well who you are I often think that
you know one of the things I say to
people who write to me asking for advice
is figure out what are your
non-negotiables and then don't negotiate
right so for example I never wanted to
have kids yeah I knew it when I was
young it's like now I'm not going down
that road I don't need the hassle don't
need the mortgage don't need all that I
want to be free to [ __ ] off and quit
this job and you know do whatever I knew
that really young and if I met a woman
who wanted to have kids I don't care how
hot she was how wonderful she was I you
know I didn't want to go down that road
because I knew we would eventually have
to split or she'd end up and this
actually happened where I was with a
woman who was like it's okay else you
know I don't need to have kids
yeah and it's like wait a minute now
that's gonna end badly
what happens is you drag them down the
path and in Nellore path yeah they'll
become resentful or eventually she'll
get you to cave and right and then
you're resentful someone's giving up
something in that situation something
big something yeah right these things
that are that are mutually exclusive and
in this case however the the the thing I
would posit is sometimes those
non-negotiables change over time as well
I was the same exact way never one of
kids and that was part of my
non-negotiables and then I met backs and
like I realized she already had when I
met her she had a one-year-old and she
just got out of this marriage and I
realized like okay this is a
non-negotiable for me let me let me
assess this and do so in a way that that
I can determine whether or not this is a
path that I want to go down does this
negotiable change over time and so for
my 28 year-old self it's one of the
biggest reasons my marriage ended is
because I didn't want to have kids but
now my 37 year old self I've decided I
also have to fully embrace it - you
can't be you know sort of one foot in
the water here I have to it's either all
in or not in at all right and and so
also understanding that that as your
life changes some of those negotiables
can change and it's probably worth
looking at you're not on the go
every year and saying okay is this still
something that I believe in and like
that or does it room or is there good
reason for it to to change yeah I think
the the thing that I would say to handle
is an emotional base is important for
all relationships not just intimate
relationships I mean if you want good
interpersonal relationships and also a
good relationship with yourself so going
back to what you had to say then yes you
have to have this strong emotional
foundation because you can have the very
rational person but if they're
constantly you know lashing out in rage
or something then they don't have that
strong emotional base then they're not
able to be to behave rationally my pithy
answer Ryan is instability is the
birthplace of chaos and and and I think
that that sometimes we what happens as
we go with the flow for a while and we
end up with the partner who maybe does
or doesn't want to have kids or we go
with the flow a little bit more and
we've bought this oversized suburban
house with a 30-year mortgage we go with
the flow a little bit more and all of a
sudden I've got three cars because I
have to fill out my three-car garage you
go with the flow you go with the flow
and and it's ostensibly stable but you
didn't quite you didn't do any of these
things intentionally it was just one
small digression seemingly small
digression after another and so you're
buried and instability and and all of a
sudden this thing that seemed stable did
because it was some template you've been
sold this meme of the American Dream or
whatever actually yields chaos if you
didn't do it intentionally now if you
want the the three-car Garage house in
the suburbs and you want the the four
kids and the two dogs and the one cat
and you you do that intentionally great
I say no one's you shouldn't deprive
yourself of that but don't think because
that's one person's template it's
necessarily your template yeah well my
pet the answer is having a healthy sex
life is going to be different for
everyone
and my experience great sex happens when
it's consensual and all parties
preferences are respected and supported
I mean that's really my way of saying do
you need to have animo
no connection with someone in order to
have like good sex I think that that's
different for everyone some people I
know girls who are very much comfortable
with their bodies and they like to go
out and hook up so like they will go out
find a guy whether they have emotional
ties or not they they feel very sexual
and they want to have that experience
and and that's all they want to have and
they never talk to that that person
again like that's I support people's
preferences good that sounds like they
have a very strong emotional foundation
so somewhat themselves absolutely yeah
and which and when I was getting at is I
think you're interpreting this question
correctly I think that I'm looking at it
wrong because yes like I think
ultimately in order to have great sex
like you have to be emotionally stable
yourself first even before I think in
any relationship before you really dive
deep in and cultivate a great
relationship it you know it's that's the
whole thing with putting the oxygen mask
on yourself first before you can help
others I think the same can be applied
with sex like like you're like you're
getting out like that specific person
that I'm talking about she's very
comfortable with herself she's very
emotionally stable and she likes to go
out and have sex and that's what she
does and that's that's totally fine but
yeah it definitely so I do I'll show you
after what Dan Savage I'm sure you're
familiar with Dan he has this term
ggg-good giving and game yeah and I
think that's what your answer so I just
wrote that right next to your answer
here Ryan you have to be you want to be
good at sex whatever good is for you and
your partner or partners giving meaning
you're not just taking from the
situation which is quite honestly what a
lot of men do is is I'm just going to
try to take from from this and as soon
as I orgasm then of course the act is
done well because in many cases it is
done and then and in game is willing to
do anything you know within reason right
so if your partner wants you to partake
in something even is something you're
uncomfortable with being willing to do
that as long as it is within reason
you're going to have your
non-negotiables obviously
well yeah totally agree alright our next
question is from Michael how should one
respond when people are surprised when a
couple chooses a traditional route like
waiting until after marriage to live
together and have sex people seem really
confused that my fiance and I haven't
moved in together yet oh man I can't
wait to hear what Chris has to say this
is so I have a hit the answer for you in
that I want to unpack it a little bit my
fifth the answer is no response is often
the most appropriate response I mean if
you're having people just criticize you
that don't have the complete picture
you're not required to respond and I
think quite often we forget that that
you aren't required you don't owe
anybody a formal response because
they're not in a line with what your
decision is no I totally rage the same I
pet the answer is along the same lines
people who challenge your values and
beliefs are not entitled to a response
so to your point like yeah someone if
someone is especially criticizing your
values and beliefs we we naturally want
to defend ourselves we naturally want to
say well I'm doing it this way because
of these reasons because we want to be
okay with our decisions but just because
we feel that way doesn't mean we have to
elicit that yeah to other people I think
the data shows that and not even the
data was just the empirical experience
of everyday people it's not the best
idea to wait till after marriage to move
in with someone and have sex with them
I'm not saying that you can't have an
outstanding one of our closest friends
Adam who waited till marriage and has
been married for many years has four
kids together and like because he has a
particular set of religious beliefs that
you know preclude him from from having
sex before before Maher or you know
having sex before marriage I think I
think though that like you don't really
understand what you're necessarily
getting into well well I yeah it's very
cultural you know your friend Adam he's
coming from a cultural context where
those things make sense and for him to
behave outside of them would be
disruptive and unfamiliar and probably
create problems with his family in his
community you know is some of the most
stable marriages in the world are
range marriages right yeah right where
they're certainly not having sex they
don't even know each other
necessarily before they get married so
you know there are cultural
considerations that need to be taken
into account but you know your point is
well-taken sexual compatibility is
something you don't know really until
you experience it I always tell people
is from a Western you know sort of
secular background if you don't have
those religious considerations I think a
really good thing to do before you make
a serious commitment is travel together
because travel brings up a lot of
attentions because there are so many
variable variables exactly so many
surprises and so you can see how people
deal with stress you can see how good
they are communicating you can see how
you to resolve because you're gonna have
issues you know she wants to go see the
pyramids you want to go down the Nile
like well we got to work this out how
does that happen you know so I think it
good like three months I'm not talking
about a week I'm talking about several
months on the road at the end of that
you'll know yeah yeah so if whatever
your cultural context precludes you from
having sex before getting married or not
living together before getting married
this is maybe a bit of a way to hack the
system yeah yeah all right well yeah I
mean I doesn't have to be sex but it has
to be some some challenging intimate
experience I think can be really helpful
yeah yeah and by the way sex should get
better over time is is at least my
experience if you are if you're
comfortable with each other because yes
the chemistry that we talked about
earlier it wanes significantly after the
first year 90 days first year that that
chemistry is going to wane but but what
isn't going to wane is your willingness
to experiment or try new things and be
open with each other and I think the
compatibility can grow after after the
first year yeah absolutely I mean I
don't I don't want to say sex should or
should not be any way but yeah ideally I
agree man like finding a partner being
able to yeah explore as time goes on and
make sex a much better experience much
more enjoyable experience man this whole
this the not living with each other
before getting married or like not
having sex before marriage like there's
nothing wrong with having those values
right um you know the what to me when it
comes down to for for Michael here is
why is Michael doing this like are they
doing this because they are you know
really devout Christians and this is
what they believe in and they are really
making their actions their short term
actions aligned with their long term
values and beliefs or is it something
that they're doing just for their
parents or that they're doing just for
you know for their friends so I think
that is where that's that's where the
decision can be wrong is when you're
doing it for other reasons than for you
and your partners so who are you doing
this for and if you're doing it for you
then that makes sense if you're doing it
to appease someone else here's the thing
you we just did an episode on parents
Ryan had a funeral for his relationship
with his father back on episode 145 and
you you I think part of that was I
realizing that you weren't ever going to
be able to appease his set of beliefs so
long story short he is a very devout
Jehovah's Witness my my partner and I
live together we you know even though I
think at this point like there's a
certain point where if you live with
someone long enough like you have to
have a legitimate divorce if you move
out like there there isn't like yeah
we're common-law yeah but I mean and
it's different every state into the
country but anyway um because Mariah and
I are not married my father essentially
just called me he's like hey man I just
want to let you know that if you have an
emergency feel free to reach out to me
but other than that I'm not even gonna
have them a meal with you because of
your misconduct I mean you know just
kind of going down that way so so I had
one or two choices man I could either
cave in and get married or you know I
can live up to what I feel like is a
meaningful life and you know ultimately
I don't
Merrigan I think I think it's I think
the piece of paper is for me and from
riots a little it's a little silly it's
a little antiquated I really love waking
up every morning and not feeling like oh
I have to be next to this person there's
a piece of paper that says I have to be
here I like waking up every morning in
like choosing to dive into that
relationship every single day I mean I I
wake up with Mariah every morning and I
and I seriously I'm like oh wow I am so
happy to wake up to you every single
morning it is so awesome to wake up next
to you every morning and I tell her that
most mornings if we were married I don't
know if that feeling would change I'm
sure wooden but there is a factor there
when you are forced into doing something
so I'm just this is me rambling and
saying why Mariah and I aren't gonna get
married personal we have nothing against
marriage we just we just aren't
religious and we aren't gonna get
married ourselves but my point is is
that I have I have taken the judgment
that my dad has given me and I have
essentially been able to look at that
and say okay that's your problem that's
not my problem and I'm gonna go ahead
and like let you live your life and I'm
gonna live my life and I would say the
same thing for Michael I mean if there's
people who aren't supporting you with
the the values that you and your partner
have instilled and that you're acting on
I mean that's you might want to question
whether or not you want to how much you
want those types of people to be
involved with your life and with your
relationships
yeah well PS Ryan we have one more
question okay
vetti asks high libido versus low libido
how can couples work on finding what
makes them both happy and if you all
want to hear our answer to that question
you can listen to this week's PostScript
episode over at the minimalists private
podcast it's available exclusively to
our patreon supporters so if you want to
support our show keep it 100%
advertisement free because
advertisements suck then head on over to
the minimalists comm slash support in
addition to our weekly PostScript
episodes the minimalist private podcast
feed includes our monthly ask the
minimalist anything episodes unreleased
recordings of our live events and the
entire back catalogue of past private
episodes you can find all the details
and all the good stuff over at the
minimal
komm slash support and here is a snippet
from this week's PostScript episode I
agree with you that it's important to
look for somebody who's got you know
libido in the general range but the
problem is that libido changes over life
so much you know a woman gets pregnant
that can have effects menopause has
effects stress you know any sort of work
stress a death of a parent you know
anything can affect libido it's it's
very malleable in that sense so even if
you are lucky enough to find somebody in
alignment with you you're gonna
experience these sort of disconnects
over time if you stay together all right
now it's time for our added value
portion of the show so we each talk
about something that has added value to
our lives recently I wrote this down and
knew we'd be talking a little bit about
sex toys today but there's a website
called oh joy sex toy ok calm okay and
it's like little comic strips about sex
toys and it's like this husband and wife
couple who and a very upfront way just
talk about their experience with
different sex toys and like I like this
one but my wife didn't like it or I kind
of like this my husband didn't or this
is pretty good but I don't think it's
worth the money or wow this thing is
amazing if you're like this but if
you're not like this then not you know I
would try this and so but they do it
with a comic strip and they put out news
like a review on sex toys essentially
yeah but but via like you know peanuts
or something
type comics so yeah you can check that
open like that in the show notes Ryan
what's been adding value to your life
recently I just came across the podcast
called philosophy bytes dude is so good
it's like these little 20-minute
excerpts of like it's not even expert
it's a 20-minute podcast of different
topics on philosophy Mariah and I we
were like sitting at the airport and we
had some time to kill him like let's you
know look up a new podcast so we haven't
we haven't listened to and we came
across this one and it was a 20 minute
podcast on why Buddhism is the right
religion now
it didn't convince me that Buddhist
Buddhism is a right religion but it was
this very interesting take on on
Buddhism and its philosophy and and I
certainly was able to take away a couple
little nuggets too to apply to my own
life from a 20-minute podcast and they
all of their podcasts are that's why
it's philosophy bytes it's like these
little bites of philosophy totally worth
it in like yeah really short and easy to
listen to what about you man what's
going on here like what what's what
podcasts are you really loving right now
is there anything that stands out I've
listened to Malcolm Gladwell's podcast
revisionist history and it's fantastic
really good listen to all of that when I
was on the road recently in Colorado
more very recent I just listened to
Chuck Palahniuk with Joe Rogan yeah it
was fantastic and a great story about he
talked I mean they were like exchanging
stories it was almost like this they
were dueling stories between the two of
them and they were getting to know each
other I like that when Joe doesn't know
the guy or the person and you can see
like it was really awkward at the
beginning because he had this wrong and
they had a rhythm yeah exactly here's
what I know about you and Chuck's like
that's not me embarrassing to go from
you but like the stories I mean he was
Chuck Palahniuk was was built for
writing and in the way in a weird way
though he's an extroverted writer which
is is is uncommon but like he the way he
developed stories is going he goes out
and tells and talks to people about
stories and so he's he's actually good
at the auditory storytelling and he
listens like he pulls anecdotes from
other people and he writes them down and
he like captures them and he has like
you know he treats his notebook is sort
of the the way to capture those little
nuggets of thought and philosophy and
then shapes it into a story the story he
told about who's the gal who wrote wild
Cheryl Strayed yeah oh my god I won't
even ruin it here because I wouldn't I
wouldn't do it justice
yeah but it was such an intense story
no I think it's episode 11:55 cash now
put in the show notes so I can look at
so I can reference it later I might be I
may be wrong but it's somewhere right
around there just in the last week or
two yeah yeah it's it's really good so
what we'll throw a link to that in the
show notes as well but you've been
you've been traveling around quite a bit
you've got the I think you've a name for
your your little R Darla Joe Vance I
really appreciate what you're doing with
your podcast because you are pursuing
your curiosity in a way that most people
are discouraged to do once they've
turned 18 and if they've they've yeah
you're like you have to you have to you
know you are you've turned 18 and here's
six figures worth of debt you have to do
this one thing for the rest of your life
I was with a new have a good life I was
with an uber driver in in Portland
recently and she was going to school to
be an insurance actuary and I'm like
yeah but I'm like that's cool like if
that's what you want to do she's like
well it's it's a job I'm like well
you're getting ready to go through four
more years of school for it's a job yeah
is this what you're curious about one no
but that's how you make money through
math and I'm like that's not the only
way to make money through math there are
mathematicians who make more and and the
thing that I really appreciate about
about what you do with your podcast is
you you literally just you know you
drive a van around North America and
talk to people who sometimes you've you
don't even know their last name yeah
there was a musician you had on recently
you're like I was Steve Steve what's
your last lesson I have a piece of paper
print why do I print out piece of paper
and have it in front of me
like Chris is thinking I would be more
like you guys you got all your notes
written out here and your your I've been
doing I'm in like episode 350 or
something and I'm still like I don't
have an outro written down or an intro
I'm just winging it it's it's sloppy but
I was at the beach my vibe
being on your podcast was that was one
of my favorite podcasts cuz it was we're
just chilling in your backyard yeah and
it was like really laid-back and the
only reason I like this format with
having a pieces of paper because I will
ramble and ramble and get off-topic if I
don't have some kind of structure I do
need structure in my life a couple years
ago I left there with and it was almost
a little throwaway line but it struck me
now sometimes there's just these little
throwaway bits this just stick with you
Ryan was telling some joke about
masturbating and and he's like and then
afterward I'm just like oh my god what
am i God and all was hey man I think
you're doing it wrong to give you points
on masturbation but but like like that's
the thing that I think was Kafka who
said life's most profound truths cannot
be discussed only via jokes and and part
of that was like what you were saying is
you were brought up to feel shame for
masturbating right and what you're
saying is well if you're feeling shame
you're doing it wrong like not doing the
act of masturbate but like
psychologically you can let go of that
shame it's it is not a prerequisite for
for enjoying yourself
the shame isn't so like but but that's
the thing about your pocket you do these
Toma and Roma episodes talking out my
ass and and never-ending ranting out my
ass yeah and you'll do that and it's
almost you said it's a mess but it's
like the most beautiful mess so thank
you so thank you for what you put out
into the world I really appreciate that
yes and speaking about what we're
putting out in the world real quick we
have a segment last segment here called
right here right now where we talk about
what's going on in the lives of the
minimalist Ryan I couldn't make it to
our gay dodgeball final it was your idea
and you've missed more games than anyone
on the team Josh you want to explain
yourself I have a five-year-old daughter
oh whatever
Navy sitter was out of town I love
dodgeball man that's like the only sport
I've ever been any good actually we
joined this gay dodgeball league we
don't know it was I mean it was totally
fine but like we show up there and let
there were the only six straight people
there there were there were more
straight people on our team I think than
any other team because I one of the
dudes were like they were talking to
their friend and he was like look at
this he's like we are outnumbered this
is not ready how did we do last week
what dude I don't want to talk about it
I'm surprisingly horrible at dodgeball I
don't know I think he's I'm so wide
maybe I don't know dude I like I am an
easy target I look like I should be good
at dodgeball so I think people they
target me but secretly I'm just really
bad so I get out really quickly it was a
whole lot of fun if we didn't finish
last we finished second to last in the
tournament well that's might have been
different if you were there Milly it
probably would have been we just did a
podcast our friend Justin who read all
of our audio books
Justin Moloch has a great podcast called
optimal living daily and congratulations
to him he just hit his thousandth
episodes incredible he puts out a
podcast every single actually puts out
several books he has several other
podcasts he just reads other people's
work so he'll take like essays that he
really finds profound and he asked us to
do episode 1001 and 1008 for him I read
a short story by Zadie Smith which
seemed totally inappropriate and he
still is gonna publish it somehow but
sorry about what's go well it's back to
the life's most profound problems can be
discussed only with jokes or with
fiction and so you're able to talk about
the sort of current political climate in
a way that you can't talk about head-on
without offending everyone but it's
sometimes sometimes if you write it in
this this sort of fictive narrative all
of a sudden you're able to discuss these
things that are somehow less offensive
it's like tallahassee coats's fiction is
less offensive than his nonfiction and
then it's nonfiction to certain people
and it's strange to me because they
cover the same topics and they
essentially say the same things in fact
you can be more experimental and
moreover the
with fiction sometimes because it is
violins or the latticework of of
storytelling yeah it's like South Park
gets away with a lot of stuff you can
never get away if it wasn't a cartoon
right you know right yeah yeah the
format diffuses it something yeah not
only is it fictional but yeah it's got
this really cheesy format that you you
can't take serious even if you try yeah
no I totally agree yeah so I read what
did you read I read the stonecutter I
just picked that story because it was
short no simple and it probably heard
that story and I was like in the five do
you know about the story the stonecutter
no oh man I'm gonna ruin it for everyone
here um it's the story's about a
stonecutter who hates their job and then
they look up at the Sun and they're like
man the Sun now that's I wish I could be
the Sun that is powerful so then they
become the Sun and then the clouds
blocked the Sun they wish they could
become the clouds so forth and so and so
eventually become this mountain and
they're like man like yeah I'm fine I'm
here I did it I'm a mountain and then
like they feel themselves withering away
and then they look down and they see a
stone cutter chipping away at the
mountain so so the whole idea of this
story it's just it's it's really really
really helpful helps me with perspective
and that grass is always greener on the
other side feeling that I have I mean
I'm so glad I heard that story in the
fourth grade because any time like I get
what I want and then I see greener grass
like I do stop and ask myself like wait
a minute is it really is it really
greener but yeah that was I'm so glad
that he invited us on this show
sometimes think about like yeah you know
if you're doing the insurance actuary
thing and you've realized
yeah well I'm 10 years in you're too
scared to jump down the corporate ladder
because you've climbed too high then you
know it it may be greener if you
actually you know you you've placed your
lamb I'm mixing several metaphors here
but you place your ladder you placed
your ladder against the wrong building
it's time to you can't just keep
climbing up though it's you have to
slowly climb back down but I think
that's I think what's true about the the
grass is always greener parable is
is we need to be content with what we
currently have who want to appreciate
something better yeah yeah I totally
agree I wanted to touch touch on the
story you talked about that you read
through so I Josh Wagner he's a friend
of mine a writer he's actually the
mentor on I have a mentoring team he's
one of them one of my team members he
was explaining to me about how when he
gets really really inappropriate
thoughts because we all get
inappropriate thoughts at one time or
another and we get to decide whether or
not we get to continue those thoughts or
we can kind of try to push him away or
compartmentalize him or whatever but
specifically we were talking about how
the conversation got started cuz we were
talking about how I was saying dude when
I do like what I've done mushrooms in
the past like I start to get these these
narratives going on in my head that
really like it get kind of you know
that's what ruins my my experience with
with that psychedelic and he was like he
was explaining to me dude when you get
those thoughts he's like whether you're
on shrooms or not he's like just start
to imagine how that would make a really
good plot for a book and he's like go
ahead and play it out but with that
intention of like yeah you know what
yeah government's out to get me and uh
you know all these other paranoid
thoughts like yeah that would be an
interesting book plot wouldn't it and
then it's like it allows it allows me to
just explore ideas that normally I would
just kind of cut off but it you know now
I can take it like a really crazy wild
thought and be like what if that yeah
what if that was a story how would that
story play out closure like instead of
like thinking about or I should say not
thinking about like I'm trying to think
of the most I don't do it often but I'm
trying to think the most recent thing I
should read more Chuck Palahniuk yeah
yeah and that's what he does yeah he
really does it takes those deep dark
ugly things and create stories out of
them and I think you know what it was so
interesting about that conversation is
seeing how his psychological health was
tied to his writing because he was able
to sort of flush that stuff out of his
brain I think
yeah I can remember the last time it
happened to me watching Game of Thrones
and looking at I forget her name it's
the the Queen on there that like
everyone hates on Game of Thrones she is
sexy she yeah she is sexy but I you know
I was watching that show and after it I
started thinking I was like God like I
could not imagine being that evil of a
person like that would be and then you
know I you know you get a random thought
of like doing something evil and then
instead of looking at that thought I'd
be like oh no no Ryan you're not evil
that doesn't exist that is exists your
worlds just fantasy like I can look at
that be like like I can look at that
thought and I can look in the mirror and
be like okay Ryan I'm the devil what
would you do if you're the devil Ryan
like it totally helps me to get that to
play it out without actually playing it
our do that meditate I do yeah yeah
because I mean what you're describing is
very much like you have these thoughts
that come into your head and the the
novice tries to stop them yes but what
you learn eventually is that by trying
to stop them you energize them and so
you just sort of you know ignore them
let it go like oh there's another
thought okay let's get back to this and
by not resisting it you you allow them
to just fade out rather than energizing
them with resistance yeah the corollary
there between meditation and and playing
the story out but that's very much true
with with meditation the thing that is
most difficult is trying to stop the
thought you know I'm trying to meditate
I'm trying to do good at meditation I'm
a seven out of ten meditator today and
like well that means you're doing it
wrong right and I think the same thing
with maybe the the stories but you're
right the the the Chuck Palahniuk thing
I think I think maybe a lot of his sort
of psychological health the everyday
well-being is tied to his ability to get
those stories out of his head
it almost gives him permission to let go
via the the page this makes me think
about I was talking about that episode
on philosophy bytes about how Buddhism
is the the right religion but it's
basically about this guy who does he's a
you know Buddhist and he you know
basically puts out his argument on why
he
thinks you know it's the right religion
but the one thing that really stood out
to me was about how we have these
thoughts enter our mind and we associate
those thoughts with who we are as a
person and he basically explains how and
I'm doing bad I'm gonna do a bad job
paraphrasing this but he explains how we
might get a random thought like I might
get a thought of how I want to rob a
bank and I would never actually act on
robbing a bank and that's easy for me to
look at that thought and say oh I would
never do that but sometimes we get
thoughts that we are maybe embarrassed
about or whatever it may be and we start
to associate that with all man that's
who we are and we got to watch out for
that we're through meditation and
through the practice of Buddhism he was
talking about how you can kind of look
at these thoughts and you can kind of
let them flow through you and you get to
decide which thoughts you you grab onto
and what you act on and and what you
kind of let go and accept that yeah
there are these random thoughts that
enter our brain that doesn't necessarily
mean it's us yeah all right I think we
are like totally off topic
I'm derailed and and several tangents so
to speak we did the Kevin Rose show this
weekend oh yeah we went up to Portland
for that and it was a great conversation
we had with him he invited us over to
his house and I have this picture of him
showing us how big his microphone is
this is wife's microphone it looks like
we're comparing sex toys he's like
showing you here is the biggest smile on
his face and you're looking at like if
you're watching us on YouTube you can
see my expression there oh one last
thing before we talk about YouTube
Jim City Marcus so Ryan and I are from
Dayton Ohio one of the largest food
deserts in the country is is in Dayton
Ohio west side of Dayton doesn't have a
single grocery store and in the entire
city and so they have access to food
like cheetos and liquor at the liquor
store but not nutrition and so we're
trying help them build a non-profit
co-worker optin the west side of dayton
and we've raised just over forty
thousand dollars so far about forty five
thousand dollars twenty five thousand
from us and also our
in company asymmetrical press was able
to donate about $1,400 from from
asymmetrical and our audience has raised
the rest we're trying to get to $100,000
so if you all want to contribute to that
and provide food not just food but
education because I think that's the one
of the bigger hurdles as well just
because you have access to food doesn't
mean you have that you're going to pick
the the carrots and the kale over the
Twinkies and the Cheetos and so
providing that education as well you
know the last grocery store closed
they're over a decade ago and we're
we're trying to fix that so if you're
interested in helping out with that just
go to the minimalists comm slash dayton
and you can contribute whatever you want
even if it's just a few bucks it'll help
out a lot if you want to comment on this
episode you can do so on YouTube just
youtube.com slash the minimalists also
on youtube we're posting about one new
video every day now including some
living room conversations quickie
podcast episodes our new vlog series we
just put out the first episode is called
a meaningful life basically just a
little synopsis of what happened over
the course of a month things that we
find meaningful we've got some
minimalist home tours and some video
essays coming soon and if you want all
of our podcast show notes in your inbox
you can sign up for email lists over at
the minimalists comm Ryan you got
anything else worth
here are some voicemail comments and
tips from our listeners hi guys I'm
Brittany originally from Montana and now
living in New York I wanted to call
because you guys speak a lot about
intention well I believe that intention
is important when buying I also think we
should use intention when we're
decluttering for example I'm a huge
movie fan and recently got rid of over
60 DVDs instead of dropping them off at
the thrift store to be sold I donated
them all to my local library like so my
boyfriend was finally ready to give up
his xbox so we found a local shelter
that frequently has children and we
donated the games and consoles to them
well it does create a few extra trips
your things can really create value for
someone else if you let them hide your
show Ryan and Soraya from Brooklyn
I just finished listening to your
patrons podcast I in-depth it and it
came to my mind a couple of months ago I
finished reading book from Rachel's and
her dad market smart money's market
something like that and they've talked a
lot about chores giving their kids tours
and give you some paying them for those
chores so I have to repeat and they each
one have chores to do make their bed my
older daughter do my younger daughter
the hair every morning the old daughter
my daughter got a vacuum of course
there's a lot of chores that they know
they just have to do without getting
paid just because they are part of the
family and it's their house too and
everybody has to help but paying them
for chores
teach them the relation between work and
money and how anything in life is free
you have to earn it so I recommend that
book to every parent every grandparent
it's really amazing and they took a lot
of how they did it when they were
growing up and what that family came
from bankruptcy to what they are right
now it's really really really good hi
guys this is Molly in Detroit I am
calling in response to an heiress
question about Herzberg collection among
knitting crocheting etc circles this
collection of supplies is often called
stash you guys are right in saying that
this type of collection is is primarily
just for when items so it's certainly
better than just in case items but the
collection of these just for when items
can also become out of control
there's a term crafter shoes called
sable which means staff accumulation
beyond life expectancy and
if something is that's not to achieve or
even approach first thing to do is
probably to establish a maximum size for
your stash and where you'll will contain
it and then think about what your ideal
would be there are some things you may
want to minimize because you find your
taste has changed since you bought them
or if you're honest with yourself they
were really just in case purchases or
just oh this is a pretty shiny thing and
I want it purchases there are other
things that you're going to want to keep
and you need to focus on actually using
them and making that win become now from
my part I've been knitting down my
fashions before I discovered the
minimalist it satisfies now that I feel
fairly comfortable with but ideally I
would get to the point where I only have
the project I'm working on
maybe one complicated project in one
simple project and then the yarn for the
next project I want to start that way
I'll be able to make things when I'm
still excited about the project because
I'm really excited when I buy the yarn
and then years later I'm not so excited
but being able to make it well I'm so
excited and then also maintain the
ability to start something new even when
I can't get to the store somebody else's
ideal stash might be bigger than that
but for anyone who retains that creative
supplies just for when not just knitters
but anyone
I urge you to think about just how far
off that when probably is and set a
limit for yourself
alright Joe that's almost it for this
episode if you have a question for the
minimalist give us a call for zero six
two one nine seven eight three nine you
can also email a voice memo to podcast
at the minimalists comm we're especially
looking for questions about discipline
spouses and preferences or personalities
and I just want to say thanks to Chris
for for being here Elsa ma'am appreciate
so much appreciate what you're doing
folks can find you on twitter at that
chris ryan tangentially speaking is is
the podcast your website tangentially
speaking comm or chris ryan PhD comm
all right sex at dawn oh also yeah check
out the books accident and we are proud
supporters of his podcast on patreon so
absolutely yeah you know that 1 million
dollars a month your Chris thank you so
much for being here my pleasure you're
awesome
all right Jeff you'll leave here today
with just one message we hope it's this
love people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for listen
y'all we'll see you next time bye and
minimus